le client a toujours raison mais pas
tout le temps tout le temps prenez
l'exemple du monsieur qui a poursuivi
cosco cosco avaient annoncé sur internet
des ordinateurs à 2 dollars une aubaine
comme ça on serait fou de ne pas en
profiter alors monsieur dans n'a pas
acheté un ni deux mais disent évidemment
c'était une erreur d'affichage cosco
rapidement annulé la transaction mais
selon le client le commerçant n'avait
pas le droit de faire ça parce que selon
la loi un vendeur ne peut pas exiger un
prix plus élevé que celui qui est
annoncé un vendeur ne peut pas non plus
faire de représentations fausses ou
trompeuses à un consommateur
alors monsieur est allé aux petites
créances en pensant peut-être en sortir
gagnant mais le juge lui a vu les choses
autrement le prix ridicule démontre que
l'erreur était évidente et que moscou
n'a pas voulu tromper les consommateurs
cette bourde à vicier son consentement à
la vente du produit alors dans la
mésentente sur les prix le client a
souvent raison mais si vous pensez jouer
aux fins renards en profitant d'une
faute de frappe vous risquez de vous
caler comme le client qui en passant a
dû payer des frais judiciaires 206 $ par
ces deux mondes
[Musique]